free at ANORO.com.
>> Jason: THE DEPUTY WHO
LOST HIS JOB FOR NOT
CONFRONTING THE FLORIDA
SCHOOL SHOOTER APPARENTLY
DID NOT TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT
HIS RESPONSE.
DEPUTY SCOTT PETERSON
CLAIMED HE THOUGHT THE SHOTS
WERE COMING FROM OUTSIDE THE
BUILDING.
BUT A RADIO RECORDING
RELEASED BY THE BROWARD
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
INDICATES PETERSON KNEW THE
SHOTS WERE COMING FROM
INSIDE THE BUILDING.
>> Jason: THE DEADLY
SHOOTING THAT KILLED 17
PEOPLE IS LEAVING STUPIDITY
FROM AROUND THE COUNTRY TO
PUSH FOR MORE GUN CONTROL.
ONE STUDENT FROM STONEMAN
DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL IS
LAUNCHING HIS OWN EFFORT TO
THE SCHOOL SHOOTING.
HE DISCUSSED HIS IDEAS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP YESTERDAY.
AND HE IS JOINING US THIS
EVENING.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Jason: WHAT WAS IT LIKE
TO MEET THE PRESIDENT AND
FIRST LADY.
>> IT WAS GREAT.
WELCOMING AND REALLY
RESPONSIVE.
>> Jason: DID HE KNOW THE
SUBJECT?
WHAT DID HE ASK ABOUT.
>> OF COURSE HE KNEW THE
SUBJECT.
WE TALKED ABOUT WHAT --
ABOUT MY SUBJECT AND WHAT I
THOUGHT WAS BEST TO DO.
>> Jason: NOW WHEN YOU SEE
AND HEAR THESE RECORDINGS, I
MEAN, I CAN'T IMAGINE GOING
THROUGH THIS AND I'M SORRY,
YOU KNOW, AS A YOUNG MAN
THAT HAD YOU TO GO THROUGH
THIS BUT WHEN YOU HEAR THOSE
RECORDINGS, AND YOU KNOW
THAT THERE WAS SOMEBODY
ARMED WITH A GUN THERE AT
THE FACILITY.
WHAT RUNS THROUGH YOUR MIND
WHEN YOU HEAR THAT
RECORDING?
>> LOOK, IT'S ABSOLUTELY
TERRIBLE THAT THEY LET THE
STUDENTS IN THE BUILDING BE
SITTING DUCKS WHILE HE HAD
AN ARMED WEAPON.
HE COULD HAVE WENT INSIDE.
HE LET THE SHOOTER ROAM FREE
IN THE HALLS KNOWINGLY.
HE WAITED FOR EVERYONE TO
DIE IN THE BUILDING ONLY
THEN TO ENTER.
THAT'S REALLY
HEART-BREAKING.
>> Jason: WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO SEE HAPPEN?
WHAT DO YOU THINK SHOULD
HAPPEN NEXT.
>> I THINK THE STOP
PREVENTION FOR VIOLENCE ACT
IS EXTREMELY -- WOULD HAVE
PREVENTED THIS COMPLETELY.
AND I'M REALLY PROUD TO SAY
IT'S A BIPARTISAN EFFORT.
GOT 15 DEMOCRATS AND 15
REPUBLICANS IN FAVOR OF IT
WHO SIGNED ON.
>> Jason: HAVE YOU BEEN ON
CAPITOL HILL AND MET WITH
SENATOR HATCH.
WHO ELSE DID YOU MEET WITH.
>> SENATOR RUBIO, SPEAKER
PAUL RYAN AND SENATOR MURPHY
AS WELL AS SENATOR MINORITY
LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER.
>> Jason: YOU HAVE THE
A-LIST.
THAT'S GOOD.
WHAT DID YOU TELL HIM?
GIVE ME THE QUICK PITCH.
WHAT DID YOU TELL HIM YOU
NEEDED TO DO.
>> I TALKED ABOUT EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF MY CONCERNS ON
THE AMENDMENT.
I SAT DOWN WITH CHRIS MURPHY
AND WE DISCUSSED WHAT HAD TO
BE DONE.
ALTHOUGH WE DISAGREED ON GUN
CONTROL.
WE DID, THE SENATOR -- WE
DID FIND A COMMON GROUND.
I THINK THAT WAS MOST
IMPORTANT IN THAT WE
REPRESENTED THAT THERE WAS A
BIPARTISAN EFFORT TO MAKE A
CHANGE.
THERE ISSUES BOTH THE LEFT
AND RIGHT CAN AGREE ON.
>> Jason: WHERE IS THE
COMMON GROUND?
WHERE DO YOU SEE THERE IS
ACTUAL AGREEMENT.
>> I THINK THE HART BILL
SPECIFICALLY SHOWS.
>> WHAT DOES IT DO.
>> HARDENS STUDENTS AND
SCHOOLS AND GIVES FUNDING
FOR TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENTS AND MAKES SURE
WE ARE SAFE.
INCREASES COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN SCHOOL AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
MAKES CORRECTIONALLIVE
PREVENTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN PROPERLY REGISTER
STUDENTS WHO HAVE MENTALLY
ILL OR HAVING LIKE MENTAL
ISSUES THAT MIGHT ACT OUT.
>> Jason: AND GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA, GOVERNOR SCOTT
SIGNED A BILL TODAY INTO
LEGISLATION.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT BILL?
>> THERE WAS ONE THING THAT
STOOD OUT TO ME AND BIG
CONCERN BECAUSE WHY THE NOW
WE HAVE PEOPLE IN THE
MILITARY SERVING AGE 18.
WE DON'T PROTECT OUR
CITIZENS LEGAL AGE TO VOTE
AND HAVE THE MENTAL
COGNITIVE ABILITY TO VOTE TO
HAVE THE SAME WEAPONRY.
THAT'S HYPOCRITICAL.
>> Jason: YOU DON'T BELIEVE
THERE SHOULD BE TWO
DIFFERENT THRESHOLDS WHERE
YOU CAN PURCHASE A GUN.
SHOULD THAT AGE BE HIGHER OR
LOWER.
>> RIGHT NOW IF A VOTER IS
ABLE TO VOTE AT 18.
REGISTER.
COGNITIVE ABILITY.
AND PROPER COGNITIVE
DEVELOPMENT TO DO.
SO IF THEY HAVE THAT
COGNITIVE ABILITY THEY
SHOULD HAVE THE SAME RIGHTS
AS OTHER ADULTS.
>> THERE IS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION SHOULD BE ABLE
TO GO OUT AND GET SOME SORT
OF RESTRAINING ORDER ON
PEOPLE THAT CAN'T
DISTINGUISH RIGHT FROM
WRONG.
ARE YOU SUPPORTIVE OR NOT
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
>> I'M REALLY SUPPORTIVE IN
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
MENTAL DISORDERS CANNOT
ACQUIRE A WEAPON.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, BAD
GUY, YOU IF YOU ARE NOT
MENTALLY STABLE YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE A GUN.
>> Jason: DEVELOPING AN APP.
>> REACH OUT APP.
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS
ALLOWING STUDENTS FROM THE
SAME SCHOOL DEVELOP
EMOTIONAL CONNECTION AND
SOLVE THEIR EMOTIONAL ISSUES
IN SCHOOL WITHOUT ANY
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FUNDING.
>> Jason: GREAT THE STATE OF
UTAH IS DOING THAT AS WELL.
THERE IS AN APP. OUT THERE.
>> 80 LIVES SAVED.
>> Jason: 86 LIVES SAVED
WITH THE APP. IN UTAH.
I HOPE THEY DO IT AROUND THE